Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 23rd, 2013. How the Hell Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's the holiday season.
Doobie Doobie.
Do at school to lead Ba ba
Ba da ba though book God,
go fuck yourself at the mall.
Um,
two days before Christmas.
Have you finished your shopping yet?
You know what? I have and I've
been traveling so much. Um,
I actually drove to a mall the other day,
but doodler dude and I looked
inside Wah Wah Wah Wah Wah.
I literally pulled up to this
fucking thing and there was so many,
I can't even say it's just so many fucking
people who are in the same situation
I am, that they just had
to go out and go buy shit.
That they actually had
people directing traffic.
Okay.
You know,
like there was some sort of flood.
They had those same sort of jackets on
like I can see you from Mars kind of
official.
Please don't run me over.
I know where the supplies are.
Jackets to direct people
in to the fucking baby gap.
And I was trying to make the light
and I couldn't make, if I, you know,
if I went to go make the light than I
would have blocked the road cause I wasn't
getting in. So I just had to
wait. And I was sitting there,
I was the first car and I just
looked at the guys in the coat.
I looked at people not moving in line
and
I just said, fuck, I'm not
fucking going in there.
And I drove away and it felt good.
I felt good like the way when you used to,
you know,
when you skipped school,
you'd be there on the way to
school and you didn't want to go.
I don't want to fucking do they
fucking hate this. I hate it.
I don't want to do it. All right. I don't
need to be taught beyond sixth grade.
All right.
And I knew it when I was a kid. I know
it. Where I around sixth, seventh grade,
I'm like, yeah, I got it.
I got it. This is, this is,
this is all I'm going to need in life.
I'm not going to design a bridge.
I'm not going to make a rocket ship,
you know?
Oh, not to manage finance.
I'm not going to use my brain.
I'm just going to be walking around
reading signs it, figuring out,
you know how much a pack of gum at a
fucking doughnut costs though. Right?
I don't need Algebra two and trigonometry.
I don't need this shit.
So then you just go,
fuck this,
I'm not going to school and you
leave and it's fucking great. Great.
Initially and then as that coming
dread of like, you know what,
now I'm going to go back tomorrow.
I'm going to have twice as much
fucking work than it did today.
Why did I just do that?
And that's what I felt like when I,
when I drove away from the mall.
Yeah.
I felt just like when I used
drive and I was driving to school,
my piece of Shit car,
and I look at my high school and I
would be fighting my fucking hand.
My whole arm is, it was trying to turn
into the school. I would literally,
I guess I would be fighting it to not
just hold it straight and keep going.
That's exactly how it felt at that mall.
And I drove away.
I drove away from that son of a bitch.
All right. And here I am Monday,
two days before Christmas.
And what have I learned?
If you don't fucking go into
that fucking Goddamn Cesspool,
yeah, you're not going to have any gifts.
And I know what you're thinking. Oh Boo.
Why did you show up as line?
We'll don't you show up on life because
I can't see it. I can't touch it.
It's just a fucking picture. I'm not doing
that. And how much shit on here is, uh,
is bullshit on the Internet. My
podcast is bullshit. All right?
Okay.
Does that even make sense?
I don't know what it means.
I'm gonna fucking going
on virtual shopping.
I get God damn.
Kids sound like a fucking old man.
So now, like the fucking asshole I
am, I have to go to the mall today,
December 23rd when I should be sitting
around with a nice sweater on drinking
some spiked eggnog.
Okay.
You know, leaning up against the
counter. I'm not getting choked up.
Just smoked a cigar yesterday. Leaning
up against the counter. All right.
I Dunno fucking just leaning there.
You know people coming over and talking
to me. Loud music in the background.
It's fire on the talking to
me and I'm not listening,
but I'm smiling and I'm not.
And you know one of those smiles,
we don't show your teeth.
You know you had the same smile is when
a kid draws a smiley face on a stick
figure. You just have that smile on your
face and you just nod your head. Yeah.
App. Yep. You're talking and I'm
listening and I'm agreeing. I'm agreeing.
I don't give a shit what you're saying
cause I'm not fucking listening cause I'm
happy right now because
of drinking eggnog.
I'm getting a little glow going
little fucking glow going.
I don't have to go to the mall.
Everything's wrapped. It's under the tree.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I don't have any standup gigs.
Ain't got shit to do until new years.
You keep talking and I'm going to keep
sitting here with my little pinky stuck
out as I drink out of these fancy little
fucking teacups that has my spike deck
knock in it, that my friends is
what I should be doing. But no,
not all freckle face,
freckle face has to go back
down to the fucking mall today,
hoping that there's enough pork sons of
bitches out there with such evil cunt
bosses that they actually have to go to
work on December 23rd they got to show
up at their cubicles.
And maybe with a little bit of luck,
I can go down there between
their half a fucking day,
run in there and buy some shit that
I then have to take home and wrap up.
MMM.
You know,
and if you're a political prisoner
right now and you're listening to this,
okay.
You know,
it's just scratching other day on the
wall trying to not lose your mind.
I know what you're thinking. You're
probably thinking, you know, well,
I would love to have some
problems like that. You know?
And you know what I say to you?
I say to you, ah, you know,
walk a day in my fucking shoes. All right.
They're just stuck in a prison cell.
Haven't seen loved ones in 12 years.
Okay.
You know,
if your present self so bad,
how the fuck did you get a fucking
device to download this podcast?
So you had to listen to it. Once you
explain that one political prisoner,
did they give you a keyboard to writing
some questions here to make me feel
fucking bad?
MMM.
I just did that before somebody
went first. World problems.
Okay.
You know what I hate more than anything.
I hate fucking expressions.
Not expressions like a
stitch in time saves nine.
Okay.
Which actually makes sense, which
I can kind of equate to, you know,
by the present today.
So you don't have to fucking wait
nine hours in line on Monday.
I just hate when a,
okay.
I Dunno like a boss.
Okay.
Shaking my head. I just fucked.
I don't mind them. I just,
I hate how they're just
continually used to the point
I that, that people are still
expecting a laugh. It's like,
how many fucking times
have you heard that?
How many times you've heard that
come into your own fucking mouth,
right? Oh my God, I am in a fucking
mode today. And you know why it is.
It's because I have to go
Christmas shopping. Um,
and also because I bought him new mixer
and I bought a more compact one that
would be better for travel.
And the guy goes,
do you have all the wires that you need
that Mike? Yeah, I got all that shit.
I'm good.
Thank you very much.
And I come here and there's just a little
bit of a different setup and I pressed
every button,
I plugged the wire and every place I could
fucking plug it in and I can't figure
it out. All right. For
you tech people out there,
I have the Mackie four oh two
V as in Victor, l as in Lucy,
Z as in Zebra, four. And I can't figure
out how to fucking use it. So whatever.
I'm holding this up like a microphone.
I'm starting to like this
to be honest with you.
MMM.
Anyways, for those of you who, uh,
you know, we're out there shopping,
doing what you should be doing,
building snow forts and whatnot. Um,
I did a very special podcast this
week with one of my favorite people,
not only in this business but also
in the world. Uh, Dave Kapner,
David Kempner from the hilarious
new site last night. Uh,
anchorman two,
the legend of Ron Burgundy continues.
Um, I interviewed him this past,
uh, was it Friday, I think?
Yeah. Friday uploaded
it just in case you, uh,
didn't check to see,
check your Twitter account or ever the
fuck you find out that there's a new
podcast. So I interviewed him, we talked
about anchorman and all this other stuff,
hanging out, getting drunk together
and singing holiday songs and all that,
which had a great time and uh,
and was recorded.
It was recorded live at
the new all things comedy,
a podcast studios.
So with that,
eventually,
hopefully I'm going to occasionally
have a guest and they'll just be bonus
podcast.
All right.
I'm not going to be reading any fucking
advertisements and all that shit.
It's just going to be,
oh well I say that now.
Who knows what if I throw out
my funny bone and I'm like,
I can't do my standup anymore,
then maybe I'll have to do with why.
As of right now,
I plan to do it and a pure fashion,
I'm not reading any shit
about chocolate covered fruit.
about fucking how to,
how to have your own goddamn lemonade
stand in your bedroom. I'm not doing that.
I'm just going to enter a
interview some people. Um,
so David Kenner is the first one
and uh,
Jay Moore is going to be my 72nd guessed
now in between him Kepner and Jay more.
I don't know what I'm going to
have, but that's all that, that's,
I'm just giving you guys the
heads up. Okay. There we go.
Um,
so anyways,
I don't have a lot to talk about this
week for the simple fact that I'm off the
fucking road and other than the fact
that I have to do my Christmas shopping,
I am excited that the, uh, the year's
over, but I also have to keep, uh,
got to keep the act tight,
got to go to the local clubs,
got to do my little song and dance
because I have a big new year's Gig.
New Year's Gig.
New Year's.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
New Years Eve.
Everybody,
if you're fucking botox ass
is in the Los Angeles area.
I am playing at the
mighty Wiltern theater,
a theater that I drove by for years.
And I told my lovely wife,
Nia, I said, someday I'm going
to play that fucking place.
I'm going to sell it out and afterwards
we're going to get drunk and I'm going
to kiss you on the forehead. Now. God
dammit, I have booked a gig there,
but there's a few tickets left to make the
dream come true. And you're like, Whoa,
wait a minute.
Why do I just want to go and see you?
Can you sweeten the pot a little bit?
Is there anything else that you can add?
It is a new year's show is just something
else that you can add to the pot to
make me say no.
I'm not going to stay home and jerk off
to internet porn with a silly hat on
blowing that fucking trumpet. Okay. I'm
going to come down to the Wiltern theater.
What else do you have for me?
It's a buyer's market.
Everybody's trying to get me out to go
fucking twinkle toes around the God damn
fucking tiles.
All right,
well I'm going to be down there with the
entire crew of knuckleheads that I go
to the rose bowl with,
um,
every year through all doing about
10 minutes in front of me. Um,
we have rose boat droves,
bolt, tailgate legend,
the mean Joe Greene,
the Jack Lambert,
the Mike Wagner of fucking a tailgate.
Mr. Joe Barton. Nick. All right.
With this new comedy CD salute,
but we hyped right here on the podcast.
He's going to be there.
Joe Aka Joe Aka.
You need fifth. You need to lose 50
pounds before you talk to me. Bitch, Bart.
Nick will be there.
We have master chef and a and a heater.
Xtrordinair Jason Law
head is going to be there.
J Law head fan of all Cleveland Sports.
You cannot talk to Jason lie at about
sports anytime you it about your team.
He immediately just says,
I have no sympathy for you.
You won a championship in
1972 because he's never seen.
He's never seen any of his professional
teams to win a championship.
Therefore therefore he doesn't want to
hear it from you. And last but not least,
we've got Andrew feminists down there.
Andrew Feminists who brings other
spirits that will not be mentioned to the
tailgate.
He's also the one that has to sift through
all your fucking emails every week to
this podcast. And he
has mentioned to me, uh,
he wants to do it a little
more efficiently. All right,
so here's how we can do it. Um, if you
want to send in an email to this, uh,
this podcast,
the low technology Monday morning podcast,
this is where you send your emails
to, all right, you send it to bill.
That's bravo illness,
Lupus, lupus. Uh, Bill
bill@themlmpodcast.com.
All right.
And the MMP in Mlm podcast
are all capitalized.
bill@themmpodcast.com. All
right. And he would please,
he's asking you nicely to just say,
please make the subject be reveled
relevant to your email. All right?
Just don't write like a hey can face
or whatever. I mean, he could do that,
but unless you're, if, if you're not
writing about Khan faces, then you know,
if you want your shit read,
help us out here.
Please make the subject be
relevant to the email. And he says,
I read emails that are great, but they
have shitty subjects and vice versa.
Oh, so in other words, don't give
a great subject to a shitty email.
Email number two,
please keep them less than 10,000 words.
Some people write great stories,
but they are too long for the podcast.
In other words, I suck at reading
out loud. And last but not least,
I know a lot of people ordered some tee
shirts and, uh, we're doing a bang up job.
Andrew is getting everything out there.
Um,
unfortunately this is a crazy
time of year. Occasionally
merchandise has gotten lost.
99% of it has not gets
lost or stolen in the mail.
Who knows what the fuck
they're doing out there.
I'm out of the 2000 plus orders that we've
had. We've had like what are we up to?
I Dunno how many,
I think we've had maybe like 10 or
11 that had a problem out of 2000.
So, and know this. Okay.
If for some reason,
whatever you ordered doesn't get there
in time for Christmas and anything,
just let us know in a nice generally
lady like way. And I swear to God,
I'll send you some extra
shit. I'll autograph it or
whatever. Okay. There you go.
Anyways, so on back to
the podcast here. Um,
okay.
Speaking of reading out loud, I only have
a, we only have two reads this week, so
yeah,
you guys don't have to worry about me.
Annoying the shit out of you with my,
my reading out loud, my lack, my lack
layer of, of reading out loud scales.
Um,
so I'm doing New Year's eve and uh,
I was actually thinking the other day on
a buddy of mine who was going out to go
do a new year's give giggers coming up
there and we were talking about how funny
it is when they give out the noisemakers
before the show starts and just who is
the fucking asshole who came
up with those fucking trumpets?
Those things that just hit that note,
Hey,
hey,
I think it was so many, just hated new
years or never got invited to a party.
And he's like, all right,
you got to go out to a party.
I'm just gonna make this fucking horn.
That's gonna annoy the
shit out of everybody. Um,
which reminds me to tell every comedian
out there, whatever Gig you do,
make sure they don't hand out the fucking
noise makers before you go on stage
because there is no comeback to,
hey, I'm all right. Here we go.
The advertising for this
week, man. Great. Everybody,
this is the holiday season. Dooby
dooby do think the fucking man, Greg,
what is the man great you ask?
They are 100% made in America.
Cast iron grilling grapes that are
revolutionizing the way people grill named
one of 2012 best grilling accessories
by men's health magazine. Man.
Great man. Grades are the perfect gift
this holiday season. Click on the man,
great banner at Bill [inaudible] Dot
Com for the 1999 holiday special.
Remember each Monday morning podcast
order comes with a heavy duty grilling
brush. Again, that's the man
Greg Grill enhancement system.
Order today at [inaudible]
dot com and lastly,
but not leastly Hulu plus everybody.
You've probably tried
hulu.com now with Hulu plus,
you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit TV shows and a selection of a movies
on your television or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet.
And it all streams in HD for the
best viewing experience with Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite current
TV shows like Saturday night live
community and family guy.
You could also check out exclusive
content including Hulu originals,
like the awesome starring SNL Seth Meyers,
who's got his own talk
show coming out soon. Uh,
and moon boy starring Chris
O'Dowd from bridesmaids.
Hulu plus also offers a great selection
of a claim films for only 799 a month.
You can stream as many TV shows and
movies as you want wherever you want right
now. You can try Hulu plus
for free for two weeks.
When you go to Hulu plus.com/bill
that's a special offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so
you get the extended free trial and that
they know that we sent you,
go to Hulu plus.com/bill.
Go to it right now or click on the
Hulu plus banner on the podcast page at
[inaudible] dot com wow.
Those were,
those were two very nice reads
if I do say so myself. Um,
all right. What are we going to talk about
this week? You know, I, I, like I said,
I don't have a lot to talk about and um,
yeah,
I did watch some American football
for the first time since, uh,
okay.
I guess the last three weeks and I
actually sat down and watch some,
I had had no idea that the cults
were in it. I thought the colts,
we're like beating every good team in
the league and then shit in the bed
against bad ones and they were all
going to be about eight and eight.
Evidently they're gonna make
the playoffs. Playoffs. Um,
I still like the Seattle Seahawks despite
the fact that they lost to the Arizona
cardinals.
Um,
okay.
I still think it is. There's
the loose. Um, anyways,
I watched the Patriots Ravens game
yesterday and I was embarrassed by that
officiating. Jesus Christ. What
the fuck did the ravens do?
That was like watching an NBA game.
Um,
and sad to say a lot of the calls,
it's not even the rep's fault.
Those are like the new rules.
Yeah.
I think for our first touchdown,
what happened was one of
the Ravens cornerbacks, um,
had the nerve to look our receiver in
the eye as he escorted of down the field.
And uh, thanks to Jim or say
that is, that is illegal now.
Okay.
After five yards,
you cannot put your hands on
the receiver and in no way,
shape or form after seven yards are
you allowed to look at the receiver.
You can't look them in the eye,
you can't look them in and
in his general vicinity.
You supposed to keep me in your peripheral
vision without touching them. Okay.
And if you sense that he is
looking back at the ball,
you then also have to
look back at the ball,
but not in the direction
of the receivers head.
You have to turn your head the same
way the receiver turned his head.
You know what they should do
at this point? They should put,
give like penalty flags to the wide
receiver and just have like anytime the
perceiver gets touched,
he can just reach in and fucking throw
the flag because that's what every
fucking receiver does.
Now when the ball sails over his head
as they're falling to the ground,
if he noticed the receivers
are our miming throwing a flag,
they throw their fucking hand up. I
don't know. It's annoying as hell.
So,
um,
okay.
I hate when I was actually surprised.
I thought we were going to lose
to the ravens. I, um, you know,
it's just,
I don't like winning like that.
We're like 20 calls all go in your favor.
I mean,
I actually saw what's his face
Harbach at one point, like watch.
And I agreed with them.
I laughed.
I felt bad for the guy and I'm
rooting against his fucking tape.
MMM.
I Dunno. This is just, it's all this
fallout of I think the concussions.
And I also think it's the fallout of
when a Peyton manning and Jimmer say had
their fucking crybaby fest when
they lost to the Patriots yet again.
And they made the tape and they went
to the NFL and the NFL was going,
that's legal. It's legal. And then they
bitched again. They bitched during the,
the fucking pro bowl.
They bitched at the pro bowl.
They pitch during the
week of the Superbowl.
They pitched right up to the
fucking draft. And then Jim or say,
who sits on the rules committee,
spearheaded all these new, uh,
fucking rules of coverage.
And I dunno,
it's not the game that I grew up with.
I still love watching it.
MMM.
I was fucking great yesterday.
Had a couple of buddies
over, got the fire going.
Uh,
unfortunate that I didn't,
it didn't get to watch the packers
Steelers with the snow on the ground.
I was watching what I watch.
I say watch the Patriots Ravens and then
I watched some of the eagles late night
game. Um, and I guess
they're playing real well.
I don't know a lot of shit that's going
on and getting caught up in hockey.
I watched a couple Bruins
sabers games, you know, one,
one we lost one and uh,
I dunno,
it's funny, a lot of, I saw what
Sean Thornton did, you know,
against the penguin's Penguin's
fans are fucking hilarious.
I think they actually have a lot of guilt
with some of the absolute animals that
they've had on their team because they're
really trying to compare going like
act like Sean, what Sean Thornton did
and everything that Matt Cooke did.
Like that's a wash,
like penalties offset like one disgusting,
horrible piece of Shit.
Move by.
Thornton washes out cooks entire three
year terror run before he turned his game
around.
Which I do give him credit for now.
He plays the game a lot
cleaner or whatever.
MMM.
I can really listen to it from any other,
anybody else other than penguins fans?
I mean you guys have all
Samuelson in your ring of honor.
I really think you're making a statement
when you do something like that.
When you put a like that up there
next to fucking Mario Lemieux.
I mean it's just, it's unbelievable. Ah,
and I was actually talking to somebody
about some of the most dirtiest players
I've ever seen since I've watched the
game all the way back to the Claudine
Claudel amuse the Dale hunters and all
those, uh, you know, in my top 10 list,
like two of them are
our Pittsburgh Penguins.
MMM.
And I think to make that list,
you have to have that reptilian sort of
brain where you can end the guys career
and like in between periods,
just sit there eating a sandwich
and you're not nauseous at all.
You just don't give a fuck.
That's scary.
That's scary fucking thing where people
on the ice have their head on a swivel.
Like, where is he, where is he? Um,
and there's a very special few,
okay.
That have debt of a,
that have done that have just
brought that vibe to it. But anyways,
I'm just like to get back into watching
hockey and that type of stuff. And uh,
there has to be a happy medium medium
with this file yet another record, uh,
Peyton Manning, congratulations. He
just threw for 51 fucking touchdowns.
But does it eve? I mean it's
these phenomenal, but with,
you can't cover receivers anymore,
so I think that they have to have,
they should just, since these new rules,
almost like the steroid era, right?
You have to have a new wing
as far as records go because
okay.
If you essentially couldn't
cover a fucking receiver
past five yards. All right,
Dan Marino all day long. I didn't want
to fucking hear it. That guy would have,
he'd had 60 touchdown, 70 touchdown.
He throw for 6,000 fucking yards.
He played when you could still mug a
receiver and he's still all these records.
I don't know.
These are all Dan Marino was the records.
It's bugging me that they
made the game easier.
Okay.
Maybe it's harder. Another layer. I don't
know. I'm just a grumpy old fucking man.
So anyways,
I don't have shit to talk about this week
and somehow I've managed to still talk
for 25 minutes because I'm
a God damn wind bag. And um,
so I was doing my usual shit.
I was going on the Internet when I
don't have shit to talk about. And a,
I was trying to find a,
okay,
get caught up on some stories.
I guess everybody from the uh,
Greenpeace 30 have been let go and uh,
okay.
Two of the pussy riot members go free and
Russia, Russia, you know, I swear to God,
if you're hippies or you're singing
in a band, they stick you in prison.
Really old school,
new prison amnesty's seemed by critics
as an attempt to ward off criticism of
human rights record ahead of
the Winter Olympics. Oh yeah.
I guess they spend a ton of
money on the Winter Olympics.
Like they bought a bunch of fake Snow
Vladimir putting in or whatever the fuck
his name is.
He bought a bunch of fake snow just in
case there isn't snow in the posh area
that they want to have the
Olympics. So, um, you know, it is,
you can put anonymous people in prison
and uh, nobody really pays attention,
but a, if they're a bunch of
hippies attached to Greenpeace,
everybody pays attention. And if they
were in a band called pussy riot,
people give a fuck. So, uh, one of
the pussy too of the pussy riders,
that's the name of the
band just got out of jail.
The third member of the Russian punk
band pussy riot. I what did she do?
Two and a half years,
uh,
released from custody following an
amnesty law passed by parliament and that
they start [inaudible].
Um,
I mean at least try to do my last name
toll of Kona Cova to Lakota rover Toilet
Kournikova nudge nudge, nudge, Duh.
No [inaudible] Tolla
Kona Cova left prison,
left a prison colony in eastern Siberia.
They put something in a fucking bat in
a punk band in Siberia on Monday hours
after another band member,
Maria, normal name Allah Kina,
I don't know how to say it was
released in another region.
The amnesty that enabled they're released
is seen as the Kremlin's attempt to
sued criticism of Russians
human rights record.
I had of the Winter Olympics
in Sochi in February.
I don't know if I'm saying any
of this right? A one. Okay.
The one of them was 25 the other 24 were
convicted of hooliganism for performing
a crude punk prayer and it could thedral
against Putin ties to the Russian
Orthodox Church. The two women have been
doof had been due for at least in March.
How much time did they do?
Okay.
I don't fucking know. Was that
even remotely exciting? Well,
if you thought that was boring, here's
another one. Here's another Russian guy,
college coalition. Nick Cough,
collision off coalition. Nigga,
what the fuck is what the
12th consonants in a row?
K. A. L. A. S. H. N. I. K. O. V.
I'm good with the cal ash.
All there is countless to cough,
assault rifle designer dead at 94
and you're probably like, Bill,
why do I give a fuck about this guy? Who
is this guy? All the rednecks know him.
This guy was the inventor of the AK 47,
um,
the assault rifle designer of the AK 47
assault rifle that killed more people
than any other firearm has died.
I'm the designer of the salt rifle.
They killed more people than
any other. He died at 94. Um,
he was in his twenties when
he created the AK 47. Well,
there is a go getter
just after World War II.
He died in his home city
of, uh, well, you know,
something that I don't feel bad for
him after what the fucking Germans did
coming into their goddamn country.
Okay,
yeah.
Here's a, here's a real
patriotic guy. He said, well,
we gotta be able to mow down these crouch
next time they come over the border.
And he made the AK 47.
So my hat's off to him.
Um,
and last,
but least this is what's going on in the
world according to my fucking skimming
thousands rally against racism in Sweden.
I was just there.
I didn't realize that they had
a neo Nazis and Sweden. Oh,
that's disgusting.
Thousands of Swedes demonstrating against
racism and Nazi-ism have gathered in
Stockholm,
Stockholm suburb a week after a smaller
rally in the same district was attacked
by neo Nazis.
What kind of a jerk off joins
a fucking neo Nazi group.
What is it about Hitler that
you're looking at going, oh yeah,
there's the guy that makes sense.
And what is it is they have nothing else
going on in their life other than the
fact that they're white. Um,
you're white, you're a white male,
heterosexual. How much further down the
track do you need to start the race?
And you still lose?
So then you got to blame somebody else
who starts nine miles in the other
fucking direction and they catch
up with you. Ah, you're whiny cuts.
Okay.
So crowds marched on Ivy.
Evidently they had an antiracism
march and these neo Nazis attacked.
You know,
is,
is there ever an uglier look on
somebody's face when they're pro racism,
when they're attacking somebody?
It's the fucking most hateful look.
Look at that son of a bitch.
So crowds marched on Sunday towards a
spot in car tarp in the south of the
Capitol where music performances
and speeches were held.
Organizers of the event said 16,000
people attended the rally. Well,
thank God for those 16,000 about a hundred
uniform police were deployed at the
event. A police spokesman that's
good. One person for every six,
1600 people. What could go wrong? Um,
and I was that right or 160.
Oh Jesus belt.
Don't be doing math in your head.
I've been to many demonstrations in my
life and this is one of the biggest.
That's great.
Said some fucking person
that I can't pronounce their
name. It shows how we many,
uh,
how many we are fighting for the equal
value of all human rights and that we are
many in comparison to the extremist.
I think many people are worried about
the rise of the far right in Europe and
want to show that in Sweden
we are taking another route.
How about you're taking a new route,
then you let the Nazis user train
systems to go into fucking Norway.
Yeah. Jesus. I actually,
it's just always going to be around.
It's just always going to be around.
And I guess how do you,
how do you think you combat that shit?
Do you have to fight it with violence?
Okay.
How else do you do it?
I these guys,
I don't understand them. I,
you're not eating every day.
Do you not have a roof over your head?
What is the fucking problem?
Okay,
that's depressing. All
right. Why did I read that?
That just put me in a bad fucking mood is,
is there anything worse
than fucking Neo Nazis?
Okay.
The sons of neonazis. Um,
anyways, let's, let's, let's,
let's read some shit here. Christmas
shopping. I talked about my new mixer.
I talked about penguins
fans. It talked about, uh,
NFL football. I don't know what
else to tell you. You know,
what is the sweet people?
I just have unbelievable anxiety.
They have to go out and shop.
And you know, it's funny,
when I actually went out
browsing the other day,
I actually saw a bunch of shit from me.
And if that isn't the ultimate sign
of what a selfish cunt you are,
mmm.
I can't find anything for
anybody. Oh, I would like that.
I would enjoy that.
Okay.
Um, all right. Anchorman two. Bill
broadcasters saw anchorman two.
It was brilliant. The whole cast is great.
Yeah, I just saw it. I fucking loved it.
Um, and went with the
Lawhead and Nia last night.
We all had a great time. Uh, they
said the whole cast is great,
but there is a level of trust
when it comes to will Ferrell.
He always makes the right decisions. Love
listening to you. Talk to David Kempner.
You definitely have to have
Jay more on. It's sometime, uh,
the running joke with Jay Morris.
He gave me shit for, not he,
I was on his podcast and I haven't
had him back on my podcast. All right.
And there is a method to my madness.
I don't think he should go on somebody's
podcast and then fucking two weeks
later you have to,
you just talked to him for God damn
hour about comedy and every other,
the other thing under the sun. You
got to let some time go by. You know,
you got to let it marinate. You got to
let it heat up. You got to let some shit,
some water go under the bridge
before you haven't back.
Plus I never have guests on this podcast.
I just don't.
But now we have a studio so I will do it.
So David Kempner was first.
Jay Morris 72nd,
so I got to have another fucking,
what does that 70 guests? Um, anyways,
he said you definitely have
to have Jay more on some time,
but don't let the whole guest
thing get out of control.
You're the master of the monologue.
Go Fuck Yourself. Uh, in other words,
keep doing what you're doing. All
right. Need an NFL team. Hey William,
I've really gotten into the NFL this
season, but still don't have a team.
I really follow being Irish
with no allegiance to any state.
I have the choice of
any team in the league,
so can either be a glory hunting
fuck and go with the Seahawks.
See even this guy in Ireland knows
that the Seahawks have the favor or the
Broncos or being long suffering cunt
to go with the Raiders of the jets.
Any thoughts yourself?
Um,
I would definitely not be a
jets fan because there is,
there is a one sip of glory
in their and their entire victory
chest there. Uh, but the Raiders,
they've won three super bowls.
They do have a great logo,
although their fan base has kind of made
a left turn with the up and all that
type of shit. The same way we kind
of have the sweet Caroline stuff. Um,
I try and block that out. I like
the Raiders, the Raiders. Also,
if you're going to listen
to them on the radio,
I think have one of the best
announcers in all the sports.
MMM.
I don't know. Just pick a team
and have a good fucking time.
I don't give a shit who you pile on
with. I mean, I wouldn't pick a team.
It's sucks. If I was trying to get into
the sport, you know what I would do?
I would pick a team that's
just underneath the favorites.
MMM.
Like, I dunno, I'm trying to
think of the premier league.
Who the fuck I would pick.
I don't know who I would pick,
but I definitely wouldn't
pick like a man United.
MMM.
I would more go man city, I
guess. I don't fucking know.
I'm going over my goddamn head.
Uh,
but I would definitely
say do not pick the jets.
Okay.
You don't want to pick
the judge, right. The jet.
I am a 45 year old man that jets have
not won a Superbowl since I was one years
old. Walking around with my
big pasty, hairless head,
pissing and shitting myself. Okay.
So that's, that's that option.
The Raiders have not won a title since,
uh, my voice just started
cracking as I was hitting puberty.
Like, do you think they're
going to be the red skins?
That's the last time that they want.
Ronald Reagan was in his first
term as president. All right.
I'm just letting you know
what you sign up for.
Let's go around the league a little bit.
The Miami Dolphins,
the Miami Dolphins have
not won a super bowl since.
Uh,
okay.
I got a cowboy outfit.
I got a hat and I got some guns,
some cap guns for my birthday and then
the big kids is, I was standing there,
came walking by,
took both guns out of my holster and it
just smashed him on the fucking driveway
and continued walking away
walking up the street.
They just came walking up the street.
They saw me standing there dressed
like Billy the kid, and they like,
that's not Billy the kid.
That's not even Billy the teen.
That is Billy the toddler.
And they walked up to me,
they took my guns out of my holster
and they smashed him on the ground,
laughed and continued walking.
I picked him up.
I walked into the house and I handed it
to my mother and she said, who did this?
And I said,
I said big kids.
And then she made me a sandwich.
All right.
Okay.
Peanut butter and Jelly.
And she left the crust on because she
didn't raise any fucking finicky pussies
when it came to food. All right.
I made you the sandwich. So,
uh, you, you, you remember
that when you were a kid,
you were going to sit there until you
finish that. Was that a dying thing?
Is that considered abuse
now and you just sit there,
you fucking legs falling asleep. And it
was her way to just keep you stationary.
She went around and clean the fucking
house. So then what did you end up doing?
You ended up taking most of the food.
Yeah.
And you fucking threw it behind the
stereo that was at giant wooden thing that
they had it on.
And you just throw it back there.
Did you finish it? Yes. Died dead
aid at all. And then that was it.
But you were too stupid to wait.
Does she walked away and went to the
store and just grab the sandwich and throw
it away?
You just left it there till all the aunts
came and then she figured it out and
then he got sent to bed anyways,
possibly beaten with the fraternity
paddle that your dad kept. All right.
I'm gonna have to go to,
you know what?
I'm going to nfl.com I'm going to go
buy all the fucking teams right now.
I'll give you a little
bit fits for the holidays.
I'll give you a little childhood
story during the holiday season.
Scooby dooby Doo and silvery bells.
Get on the fucking sleigh,
but go to grandma's senile house.
Um,
I went to the nhl.com sorry,
force of habit and F l.com.
Here we go.
Loading, loading, loading. Get
those teams go in. All right.
The buffalo bills have
never won a championship,
so there's no story for you.
That's one team.
Okay.
All right. The Baltimore Ravens
have not won a super bowl.
Okay.
Since January,
I don't have any childhood
stories cause I was an adult.
So that's a man's team right there.
The Cincinnati Bengals have
never won a super bowl.
No story for you so far.
The buffalo bills and the
fucking Cincinnati Bengals
zero titles and you want to
add to that no fucking childhood story.
The Cleveland Browns,
you take all three of them.
You stick them in a burlap sack like
a bunch of kittens you can't raise.
You throw them over the
bridge in the fucking river.
The Pittsburgh Steelers have not
won a fucking title since what?
2009 that's a good team to jump on.
They get a head coach and
they fucking stick with them.
The Houston Texans expansion franchise.
Wait a minute,
before you throw those kittens over the
bridge, we got another one to stick in.
A burlap sack.
The Indianapolis Colts used
to be the Baltimore Colts.
They have not won a super bowl.
Okay.
Since I had just stopped pissing myself,
I just learned how to sit on
that little plastic toilet,
you know,
urinate or defecate.
Standup excitedly scream at my
mother and point at it and I got,
y'all got fucking shit right.
The Jaguars never won one.
The Titans,
Aka the Houston Oilers never won one.
Jesus.
There's a lot of teams that
haven't won a Superbowl.
The Denver Broncos have not
won the Superbowl since I
didn't realize I was going
to go bald and
start balding.
I still have some left.
Um, in the late nineties,
they have not won a Superbowl till
somebody said for the first time. Hey,
have you heard of this
guy, m and m? By the way,
if you guys heard his new album yet,
Jesus Christ Jesus Christ.
Oh, fucking inspiring. Is that if
you're in any sort of entertainment,
the Kansas City chiefs have not
won a super bowl since 1970 1970.
Since Nixon was not
exposed as a fucking lie,
the Raiders already did.
The charges have never won one.
They wanna fuck an AFL title.
The Dallas cowboys have not
won one since people will win.
And Z Kava Ricci fucking pants on.
Oh, they want to want to like 95.
Right as grunge was dying.
And for some reason people thought that,
that those guys who sang,
sang glycerin was a good band.
The giants have not won one since they
broke my fucking, uh, for the second time.
Am I really going to go
through the whole league?
I think I am the Philadelphia
Eagles have never won a super bowl.
Throw them in that burlap
fucking sack with the kittens.
The Redskins have not won
a Superbowl since, uh,
since z cavalry.
She pants.
Okay.
The Chicago bears have not
won a Superbowl since 1985.
What was going on then since Cindy
Lopper was actually relevant?
The Detroit lions have not even
want to fucking championships.
I think black people weren't even allowed
to play in the NFL who maybe they were
since 1955 with Bobby Lane.
Green Bay packers is a good team to
jump onto the a Minnesota Vikings is an
adult cat that acts like a
kitten loser of four Superbowls.
Stick them in that burlap sack.
The fucking Atlanta Falcons.
Why do you have a team? I don't give a
fuck that you change uniforms to black.
Nobody gives a shit. You get
in a burlap sack, the panthers,
you're an expansion franchise.
You get in,
but you're on the top of the sack and
we'll give you a chance to crawl out.
The saints won one in 2010.
I think the bucket name
is one one in like 2002.
The cardinals have never won one.
Getting that burlap sack shut your face.
Get the sec rams have won one since
[inaudible] 99 the San Francisco 40 niners
great franchise. That's a great
team to follow. The 40 niners,
the Seattle Seahawks,
despite how loud they scream on purpose
have never won a fucking Superbowl.
They can also get into
the fucking burlap sack,
but they're also at the top of it cause
I think that they might fly out and when
one this year. So there's your
league. Those are your teams, I hope.
Makes Sense. All right, back
to the fucking questions. Um,
new Christmas tradition,
dare belly stove,
top pipe. Uh, how about
instead of Mistletoe,
which encourage you to, which encourages,
look, this is kind of the guy, right?
This guy writes this.
How about instead of Mistletoe,
which encourage you to another
person while standing under under it,
which encourage you to kiss another
person while standing under it.
There is a new berry and
a shrub combination that
suggest you go fuck yourself.
What Barry Shrub Combo would
you suggest is appropriate.
Thanks and have a jolly Holly jolly.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Jesus Christ. Dude. I
actually liked Christmas.
I thought he would say have a fucking
combination like Barry and shrub.
That means that someone, uh, you know,
some female has to drop and blow
you or a fellow if you're into that,
you know, or if you're a lesbian,
maybe you just put the shrub update.
You just have a Bush hanging from
the ceiling. Equal opportunity,
however you want to do it. But a failure,
if you got the berries on the side,
the shrub will you just sorta cut
it like a dick sort of a shape.
And then there's your unit.
I Dunno what to do with that.
Yeah. Lesbian. You just have like a shrub.
Why don't you like the missile till sir?
Yeah,
it is kind of fucking perverted, right?
Some creepy guy hanging out around it.
Nia keeps telling me to hang
up the mistletoe. It's like,
why don't you just come over and give me
a kiss? I mean, I'm glad to do it. No,
it's the truth. I should, ah,
fuck. I got to go out to the mall.
That's what I'm doing. Just go out to
the mall. I'm just going to buy shit.
I'm just going to see shit.
I'm going to grab it,
I'm going to buy it and then I'm just
going to have like do they feel like it?
That's just what I'm going to do.
All right.
Then I'm going to get some fucking egg
nog and I can only drink one glass of it,
but they don't sell just a glass.
You got to buy the whole court of it
and I'm going to get some bourbon.
I'm going to stick it in there and
I'm going to get fucking drunk.
That's what I'm going to do. Leaning
against the mantle with the fire going.
Um, ah fuck. I gotta wrap this podcast
up cause I have to go shopping.
Shopping. Do you believe
that? How do you guys do it?
How do you do the Internet thing?
Where do you go for next year?
Can you help out other older fellas
like myself that don't understand the
internet unless you're talking about porn
or trying to find out who won the game.
Did he do that for me?
Okay.
I, I did order a couple of things
off the Internet by fucking though.
I'll go to Mitchell and ness
and by myself at Jersey.
It's like I'm some make a wish kid.
But other than that,
I don't know what the fuck I'm
doing. All right, here we go.
Another creepy email yet
another creepy email. Uh,
interested in younger girl of
legal age. Okay, dear Billy blue
and your last podcast and many others
you talked about what you think is an
acceptable age gap between
people in a relationship. Oh,
by the way, that, you know,
divide by two and add seven that
that guy was taking credit for.
I like to do this. You fucking
hack the French came up with that.
Those stinky, smelly sons of
bitches came up with that one. Um,
actually the younger friends,
people don't smell.
It's the older ones instead of just
not giving into good lord those smelly
menage a trois.
Okay.
Um,
is that you or me?
I currently have a moral dilemma that
relates to the topic in which as a 20 year
old, I'm thinking about pursuing a
relationship with the girl who's 16 dude,
w w w what were in the fucking world?
Is she legal?
She asked me out recently and I'm toiling
with the decision as to whether or not
I should take her up on her offer.
Uh,
I'd like to know what your thoughts are
about this before you jump to conclusion
and start hating my guts. Let me give
you a little backstory where I live.
The age of consent is 16.
So this is 100% legal.
You know what?
I would do a search to try to figure
out where that is cause you conveniently
didn't tell you,
but if I did,
I'd end up on some list
because I would be searching,
where is 16 legal to fuck somebody?
If you go with the French divide
your age and half, that's 10.
You add seven 17,
you're coming in under the fuck in a y.
Okay.
Uh, um, uh, very young
looking 20 year old.
So what Ralph Machio ought to be able
to fuck a 16 year old. What the fuck it.
Oh my God, what did what, when
did this become to the, the uh,
to catch a Predator podcast.
I'm a very young looking 20 year old
and can easily pass off as a high school
student. You fucking creep.
If you didn't look at my id,
you'd think me and this
girl of his same age,
she's highly intelligent and very mature.
Yeah.
What is mature in your world?
There aren't just pictures in her book.
I know pedophiles like to use this
phrase a lot to justify their actions,
but I can have better conversations with
this girl than most girls my age and
older.
I wait a minute,
this is a lady I just turned 20.
And for much of the time we
are only three years apart.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
You're going to expose me for
being a sexist individual here.
All right, so you're both women. I I need,
I need and he is still sleeping.
I need a fucking females advice here,
you know, because, uh,
the way you're set up physically,
this is how dumb I am. Okay.
And don't judge me here.
Helped me because of the way you set up
physically for some reason it doesn't
seem as bad.
You know that you can,
uh,
you're not going to fuck him.
You know,
you just got to kiss him and pat them,
laugh at them.
So fucking creepy. Um, I'll
wait. There's more excuses here.
I'm sorry.
I'm,
I just turned 20 and for much of the
time we're only three years apart.
She's probably much more
experienced sexually than me
as she had previously been
in a serious relationship for
quite some time. Jesus Christ,
one of these girls start fucking,
and I've never had a relationship
that lasted more than a month or two.
Never in my entire life,
including grade school.
Have I ever had a relationship or gone
on a date with someone younger than me?
This is an entirely new territory
and I guess you can see why I'd be
apprehensive.
You keep painting yourself as the victim.
I really liked this girl
and she must like me,
but I don't know what
my next step should be.
There's no one I can really talk to
about this without them jumping to
conclusions. So any advice you can give
me would be health helpful. Thanks bill.
And Go fuck yourself. Ps, please come
to Saskatchewan. Okay, there we go.
Uh, sometime during your travels you've
got fans up here and were aching for some
high quality stand up.
Um,
okay.
All right, well what's weird
about this email is where I live.
16 is not the age of consent. All
right? So this is creeping me out.
Um, let me make sure you are a
female. I didn't read that wrong.
She's highly intelligent.
I know plenty of positives use phase,
but I can only have better concentrations.
Where did I think that she was a woman?
I'm a very young looking 20 year old
and can easily pass off as a high school
student if he didn't look at my id. You
think me and this girl are the same age.
Where did I think that this was a woman?
Am I out of my fucking mind?
Jesus Christ.
No,
I don't know. I don't know
what the fuck to think. Look,
if you're a guy and you're going to
make this fucking move, uh, it just,
I don't, I can't get out of the fact
that it's fucking illegal in my world.
And I used the French thing
cut in half plus seven,
whatever you are, man, woman
hermaphrodite just be like, look,
talk to me in 11 months.
All right.
When you turned 17 and I guess that's
legal up even more legal and I,
I don't know. I don't fucking
know. You know, go make a
snowman with them her. Okay.
I don't fucking,
I don't,
I don't want to read these anymore.
All right.
I don't want to be like giving
people examine it. You know,
it was a year old down the street and
I'm a young 14 year old and I was,
you know,
I don't like doing this stuff.
People my age do I still like playing
with matchbox cars? Fucking creepy.
All right. Cut it out. Accidentally.
Racist Story. Accidentally racist, racist,
racist. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Um, hey bill,
love the podcast and I enjoy your work.
Well thank you very much person.
I don't know if it's a man or a woman.
All I know is that they're just going
to be talking about being racist and not
trying to have sex with somebody
who's potentially or not underage.
I'm the guy that wrote in last week
about the accidental racist thing was
probably full of shit.
Okay.
He said,
I read that same subject and that accepts
exact same story on reddit over four
months ago.
No Way.
If it is the exact same guy that started
the reddit thread, then cool. If not,
then fuck him anyways.
Have you ever dealt with someone
stealing your material on stage? Thanks.
Um, ah yeah. Yes, I have. I've had,
I've had that happen not that much,
maybe like a half dozen times.
Okay.
And I just walk up to the
person, I just say, hey,
that's my stuff and I've
seen you see me do it.
Okay.
And then they never make eye contact goal.
You're going to make a big deal of
this. Yes, yes I am. And then they stop.
Um, but I think people who
aren't in this business,
uh,
they steal shit all the time.
Yeah.
You know, if you look
at like a, I don't know,
regular people can be hacky
just because there's no,
then there's nobody's judging their work.
So there's a freedom to what they do.
Uh, but passing off the Louis
Ck did a great bit about that.
Did anybody ever tell
you a really funny story?
And then like two weeks later you're
telling the story like it happened to you
and then you get halfway through the
story and you realize that you're telling
the story back to the guy who
told it to you originally? Um,
yeah. I mean, I guess people do shit
like that. I don't fucking know. Wow,
that's disappointing. That's like twice
that guy stole from them. You know,
I got this little theory
that I, uh, I like to do.
I remember one time I worked at the
comedian, he, and he said, you know,
I have this saying that I like to say,
and it's free.
Your mind and your ass will follow.
And it was like either our
parliament or funkadelic.
Yeah.
George Clinton or something came up and
this guy actually was selling this on
bumper stickers. I have a saying that, uh,
you nailed two of the hand is worth,
you know,
one of the hands were two in the bush,
but,
and I put it on his tee shirt and
I'd like to sell it. Alright, dear.
Mr [inaudible] [inaudible] face,
sorry,
the new secretary in my office is a black
woman and bake cookies for the office.
I sarcastically said,
I hope you slaved over these all night.
Okay.
She stared at me and I saw
a pure evil in her eyes.
The question now is do I eat one or is
it unspoken that they're now off limits
for me?
Uh,
I don't, well, yeah, you made a joke
and they doubled. It wasn't funny.
I sarcastically said, I hope you
slaved over these all night. Oh,
slaved over these all night.
He's has like three L's.
MMM.
Jesus Christ. Dude. Um, I,
I that make you a question.
You should buy a joke book
is what you should do.
Maybe watch some standup and
learn how to deliver them.
The only way you would,
that would,
could ever be funny as if you
knew that person really well.
And that was the
relationship you guys had.
Like you joked around about shit
like that. But to say that for,
of all the people at the office,
uh, I don't know what to tell you.
Okay.
What's your, you've matured a
selfish cunt. You don't give a shit.
You don't give a fuck about people
because all you care about now is should,
can I eat one of the cookies or can I not?
You know,
and you're probably going to be a
terrible father and have awful unexamined
children. That's what I
get out of all of that. Um,
okay.
Yeah. You're one of those people
that kind of likes hurting people.
Maybe I'm wrong,
I'm judging you on the paragraph,
but like the person that I'm picturing,
I don't fucking know. Um, anyways,
number three, hey bay there.
Billy goats gruff. Oh,
this is all the accidental racist shit
here. Uh, that wasn't accidentally racist.
That was on purpose.
Racist.
MMM.
Cause I think if it was funny,
it would have been funny and I don't,
you don't give a shit on any level
that you might have hurt that person's
feelings. All you want is to know
is if you can have the cookie CSE,
you're a cunt. Um, that's an, that's an,
that was nothing accidental about it.
Um, number three, a Billy goat gruff.
My white friend used to go to
temple university in Philly is back,
as you probably know,
it's a highly populated black area.
Now how the fuck would I
know that? Uh, I guess I,
cause I've done shows in Philly. I don't
know which areas are what. Anyways,
he was at a house party with this
chick and most likely a wee bit tipsy.
They were heading out to leave when
his gal realized she forgot her black
handbag in the other room.
Oh,
my friend told her to sit
tight and he'll go get it.
He stormed back into the
room and yelled out, hey,
is there a black person here?
Uh,
the room fell silent as he found himself
staring at an entire room filled with
black people.
When he realized,
he said he quickly snatched a purse
sitting on the couch and held it up and he
said, no, no, a purse.
It's a black purse. Yeah,
I don't understand what is a,
how did he offend people?
You said everybody figured out
what he meant and they all laughed.
He slinked out and told
all his white friends.
Did you get it? Bill? Is there a black
person here? Oh, what? Like Pussy.
Okay.
Person. Is there a black person here? Oh,
person. Ah, is there a black person here?
Ah, that's hilarious. I didn't get it.
Hugs and kisses.
That's fucking let you know.
What I love is that you realized I'm too
stupid. That if I'm reading out loud,
trying not to fuck that I wouldn't be
able to fuck in a an now you know what
that seems to fucking convenient.
Is that an old fucking story?
Did you steal that one? Two a?
Is there a black person here? Ah,
Jesus. Jesus Christ. People.
Do you not have enough
funny stories in your life?
You've got to start making them up a
number for a group of people from work,
including myself,
this is all accidentally racist,
raises a group of four people from work,
including myself,
were sitting at the front of the light
rail parentheses above ground version of
the subway in North Carolina
and drinking all day at a pub,
crawl at a pub crawl.
A group of black people came up to
sit behind us and our drunk, ditzy,
blonde coworker says,
welcome to the front of the bus.
I gotta tell you something
that's actually fucking funny.
I think that that's, I don't know. I think
that that's funny. She didn't meet. Oh,
she didn't mean it in a bad way. You guys
would just partying and she just said,
welcome to the front of the bus. I got
to tight. That is fucking hilarious.
Yeah,
that's, that one is fucking
hilarious. Oh my God.
All right. One of them was
funny. I like it. There we go.
And what do we got here?
Oh, an hour and one.
The podcast is fucking over.
Um,
we got to wrap up here.
Now that the show is over,
don't forget to sign up for your
free trial of Hulu. Plus, once again,
Hulu plus lets you binge on thousands of
hit shows anytime, anywhere on your TV,
PC,
smart phone or a tablet.
Support the part this podcast and get
an extended free trial on Hulu plus when
you go to the podcast page at [inaudible]
Dot Com and click the Hulu plus banner
or go to bill or go to Hulu
plus.com/bill. That's Hulu, Hulu,
Hulu plus.com/bill.
Sorry,
I was looking at the clock to see if I
had enough time to tell you this quick
story.
I have a pet peeve as I was walking
through the the other day and uh,
I was hating my life.
Um,
this other mall that I ended up going to
that was more like a, it wasn't a mall,
it was like this strip of stores on
a street. So you weren't stuck there.
And there was this Christmas
tree and I have a new pet. Oh,
Cleo,
you got fleas all baby.
I like my dog old baby.
I like my dog.
What's up buddy? Huh? What's up?
I actually got this dog
to like one of my friends.
I got a new thing that I do. I just
take her for a walk with all my friends,
with one of my friends and
after three walks, three hours,
she starts to accept him and then I have
her give her some water and then I have
little treats and she starts looking
at them like they're a food source.
You do that for another five hikes and
then you gradually taper off with the
food,
you know?
And it's more just sort
of patting the dog.
And then I gradually let the person
with my dog in the front yard.
We hang there for a couple of hikes
right at the end of a couple of nights,
they can take a 15 day process.
You know,
I'm sorry somebody beat you and
that you don't trust anybody Cleo.
But we're going to turn this, this
apple cart around. Are we now?
I'm trying to have mister j law had
become friends. We'll work on it. Right.
Okay. Fucking love this. Talk. Anyways,
so people is sitting there and they're
taking pictures in front of this
Christmas tree. This is such a
dumb thing to be annoyed with,
but I hate people who take pictures
with their fucking, uh, iPad.
You know,
it's just look stupid.
Like you sitting there holding the
food tray up in front of your face.
I really wish somebody would
just step in and give you a hook,
like a fucking left hook
right around your tablet,
right to your face and knocky Goddamn
dentures right out of your mouth or your
partial something.
It's just,
it's just annoying.
That big stupid fucking thing.
Why you walking around with that thing?
You know, you don't have a cell phone.
What are you doing with the thing?
I just want to fucking break it over.
My God damn knee. Sorry. Hey,
maybe that's a new segment we can
get away from the fucking, you know,
semi pedophile questions.
What is it?
What is something that it
just annoys you and you know,
it's stupid and it shouldn't
fucking ignore you lesbian.
I'm throwing my hat in the ring.
People who takes pictures with their
fucking IPAD, a tablet. I don't like it.
It bothers me.
It shouldn't bother me.
People are free to do it and I don't
fucking like it. All right. There you go.
Hey everybody. Merry Christmas. Just
hear those sleigh bells. Ring a link.
Tink, tink, tink link too.
Merry Christmas to a Christian,
a Muslim or a Jew.
I don't care.
I don't care if it's offensive to you.
It's by holiday.
I like saying merry to you.
I'll take some rouge and put it on your
fucking Jakes and make it seem like
you're happy to stop paying a fucking
con and get over by the Christmas tree.
Stop fucking content.
Get all about a Christmas tree and park.
You gift though. Sorry. Um,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you everybody who came
out to my shows this year.
This was the greatest fucking year
I've ever had as a goddamn comedian.
Um, got to play all these wonderful
venues and I'm going to next year,
next year I'm going to do another
special. Oh boy. Oh boy. Um,
probably in the April, may time a
year. I'm going to tape it recorded,
fucking put it out there,
and then I'll work on my next hour
and I'll do another fucking tour.
And I go even more fucking cities
because I don't know what else to do with
myself that said, go fuck yourself.
Merry Christmas. Happy Kwanzaa,
happy Hanukkah.
And uh,
I'll see out of the moon.